Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了巨量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向“净零”的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术和创新。每桶碳排放量平均已减少22%。他们与政府合作，创造并保护就业岗位。并正在建设世界上最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的“净零”计划正在推进中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 了解我们的行动计划。
Music On the 1st of December 1948, the body of a man was located along the seawall of Summerton Beach, just near Red Alive, in South Australia. At first the case received very little media attention and the police thought it was a pretty straightforward matter. The natural death on the beach, no big deal, just had to ID the body and it would all be over. But as the weeks and months went on it soon became apparent that this case was anything but straightforward and the further you dug into it, the deeper it went. To this day we don't know who he is, we don't know where he came from and we don't know how he died.
音乐。1948年12月1日，在南澳大利亚州红活区（Red Alive）附近的萨默顿海滩（Summerton Beach）海堤旁，发现了一具男子的尸体。起初，这起案件几乎没有引起媒体的关注，警方也认为这是一件非常简单直接的事情。海滩上的自然死亡，没什么大不了的，只要确认死者身份，一切就都结束了。但随着几周和几个月的过去，人们很快发现，这起案件绝不简单，你挖得越深，牵扯就越深。直到今天，我们仍然不知道他是谁，不知道他来自哪里，也不知道他是怎么死的。
Welcome to the mysterious case of the Summerton Man. Music On Wednesday the 1st of December 1948, the body of an unknown man was found on Summerton Beach in Adelaide, South Australia. The unknown man would come to be known as the Summerton Man. He remains one of Australia's most baffling mysteries. He was found lying on the sand with his head propped up resting against the seawall. It's a pretty uncomfortable awkward position. To this day his identity and cause of death remain a mystery.
欢迎收听萨默顿男尸谜案。音乐。1948年12月1日星期三，在南澳大利亚州阿德莱德的萨默顿海滩上发现了一具身份不明男子的尸体。这个神秘男子后来被称为“萨默顿人”。他至今仍然是澳大利亚最令人迷惑的谜团之一。人们发现他躺在沙滩上，头部斜靠着海堤。这是一个相当不舒服、别扭的姿势。直到今天，他的身份和死因依然是个谜。
Like all mysterious and unsolved cases there are many theories and a lot of wild speculation. And in this case there's a lot of information to fuel these theories and wild speculation. The Summerton Man was found with no identification. In fact even the labels from the clothes he was wearing had been removed. To this day he remains unidentified. He was found with a crumbled up piece of paper in his pocket containing two words. Taman should, which is Persian meaning finished or ended. These words were later linked to a poultry book which contained what many believed to be a secret code.
像所有神秘且未破的案件一样，这里有许多理论和大量的疯狂猜测。而在本案中，有大量的信息来助长这些理论和疯狂猜测。人们发现萨默顿人身上没有任何身份证明。事实上，连他所穿衣服上的标签都被剪掉了。直到今天，他的身份依然是个谜。人们发现他的口袋里有一张揉成一团的纸，上面写着两个字：Taman should，在波斯语中意思是“完结”或“结束”。这些字后来与一本诗集联系在一起，其中包含许多人认为的密码。
Along with the code there was two phone numbers, that of a local bank and one of a local Adelaide woman who lived only about 400 metres away from where the Summerton Man was found. The Adelaide woman said she had no idea who the Summerton Man was but many believed she was lying. Like most unsolved cases there are plenty more questions than answers. But let's start with what we do know and to do that we need to go back to Adelaide, 1948. The Summerton Man arrived at Adelaide train station on the day before his body was found, Tuesday 30th November 1948. Once arriving at the station he checked his suitcase into the plug room. The suitcase was tagged and the receipt was given to the Summerton Man.
除了密码之外，还有两个电话号码，一个是当地银行的，另一个是当地一位阿德莱德女性的，她住的地方离发现萨默顿人的地方只有大约400米远。这位阿德莱德女性说她根本不知道萨默顿人是谁，但许多人认为她在撒谎。像大多数未破案件一样，疑问远比答案多。但让我们从已知的事实开始，为此我们需要回到1948年的阿德莱德。萨默顿人在被发现死去的头一天，即1948年11月30日星期日（注：原文Tuesday为周二，按上下文修正或直译），到达了阿德莱德火车站。一到车站，他就把手提箱寄存在了行李寄存处。手提箱贴上了标签，收据交给了萨默顿人。
From a time stamp found on the suitcase tag is determined that he checked it in somewhere around 11am. The only train arriving to Adelaide around that time that was from a big city was a train from Melbourne. All the other trains arriving into Adelaide were from smaller country locations. So it's commonly thought he most likely came from Melbourne as a non-identified mystery man walking around with a suitcase probably would have stood out in a smaller country location. The locals out there don't miss too much. After checking in the suitcase the Summerton Man bought a train ticket to go from Adelaide station to Henley Beach. It was a second class one-way ticket although nothing could really be taken away from that as all tickets on that line were second class. There was no first class.
根据行李标签上的时间戳，可以确定他大约在上午11点左右办理了寄存。当时到达阿德莱德且来自大城市的唯一一列火车是一列来自墨尔本的火车。所有其他到达阿德莱德的火车都来自较小的乡村地区。因此人们普遍认为他最能来自墨尔本，因为一个身份不明的神秘男子带着手提箱在较小的乡村地区四处走动可能会非常显眼。那里的当地人对周遭的事情可是了如指掌。寄存完手提箱后，萨默顿人买了一张从阿德莱德火车站到亨利海滩（Henley Beach）的火车票。这是一张二等单程票，不过这其实说明不了什么，因为该线路上的所有票都是二等票。根本没有一等票。
Within the time frame of him checking his suitcase in there were two departures to Henley Beach. One at 10.50am and the other at 11.51am. But the Summerton Man didn't get on either train as the ticket was found unused in his pocket. Instead of boarding a train he walked across the road and bought a bus ticket to Glenelg. The bus departed at 11.15am and dropped him off about a 20 minute walk away from where he was found dead on Summerton Beach. Now Henley Beach for where he had the unused train ticket was 7km away from where he was found. So that's a pretty long walk. The thought is he probably bought that train ticket as Henley Beach was the closest train station to where he had to go
在他寄存手提箱的时间范围内，有两趟开往亨利海滩的列车。一趟在上午10点50分，另一趟在上午11点51分。但萨默顿人并没有坐这两趟车中的任何一趟，因为那张票在他的口袋里被发现时完好未动。他没有上火车，而是穿过马路，买了一张去格莱内尔格（Glenelg）的汽车票。这辆巴士于上午11点15分出发，把他放在距离他在萨默顿海滩被发现死亡的地方大约步行20分钟的地方。而他原本有未使用火车票的亨利海滩，距离他被发现的地方有7公里远。所以那是一段相当长的步行路程。大家的想法是，他可能买了那张火车票，因为亨利海滩是他要去的地方最近的火车站
not realising that there was a bus that got him a lot closer. So after talking to someone or even seeing a sign he bought the bus ticket and didn't worry about the train ticket. He jumped on board the bus would have been an old double decker back then and made the journey to Glenelg. Getting there around lunchtime. What he did after getting off the bus is anyone's guess because there's no sight of the Summerton Man again until about 7.15pm that evening. At 7.15pm a local businessman John Lyons and his wife were going for a walk along Summerton Beach. The sun was starting to set about this time. Here they saw the Summerton Man lying on the beach head propped up against the sea wall body laying out on the sand.
却没有意识到有一辆公交车能把他带得离目的地近得多。所以在跟人聊过天或者甚至看到了一个标志后，他买了公交车票，而不再管那张火车票了。他跳上了一辆公交车——在当时那应该是一辆老式的双层巴士——前往格莱内尔格。并在午餐时间左右到达那里。他下车后做了什么，谁也说不准，因为直到那天晚上大约7点15分，萨默顿人才再次被人看到。晚上7点15分，当地的一位商人生产约翰·莱昂斯（John Lyons）和他的妻子正在萨默顿海滩散步。这时太阳开始落山了。在这里，他们看到萨默顿人躺在沙滩上，头部斜靠着海堤，身体舒展地躺在沙滩上。
Just like when he was found dead. Although he wasn't dead because he raised his right arm up and then flopped it down. They didn't think too much of it they just put it down to another drunk who had won too many and was now sleeping it off and they continued on their walk. Now should be noted this is not a quiet isolated spot. There were plenty of people who used the beach and walked along the Esplanade. It was a popular location. He was laying right next to a set of stairs which led up to the Esplanade and these stairs were used regularly. About 8pm that night a young couple were going for a walk along the Esplanade.
就像他被发现死去时一样。不过他当时还没死，因为他把右臂举了起来，然后又啪地放下了。他们当时没太在意，只认为这是又一个喝多了、宿醉未醒的酒鬼，于是继续他们的散步。现在应该指出的是，这不是一个安静偏僻的地方。有很多人使用这个海滩并沿着海滨大道（Esplanade）散步。这是一个很受欢迎的地方。他就躺在一组通往海滨大道的台阶旁，而这些台阶经常被人使用。那天晚上大约8点，一对年轻夫妇正沿着海滨大道散步。
It was just on dusk. They sat down on a bench right next to the staircase where the Summerton Man was laying down below on the sand. Here they saw an unknown man in a hat standing at the top of the steps. He appeared to be looking down at the Summerton Man. This man was never identified and was never seen or heard from again. No one knows if he's related to the case or not. The young couple looked down and they could see the legs of the Summerton Man but their view of the top half of his body was blocked by the staircase. They didn't see him move but they did report that by the time they'd left the bench they thought his position had changed.
当时正值黄昏。他们坐在紧挨着台阶的长椅上，而萨默顿人就躺在下方沙滩上的台阶旁。在这里，他们看到一个戴帽子的陌生男子站在台阶顶端。他似乎正低头看着萨默顿人。这个男人从未被识别身份，也再也没有被看到或听到过。没人知道他是否与此案有关。这对年轻夫妇往下看，可以看到萨默顿人的腿，但他们对上半身的视线被台阶挡住了。他们没有看到他移动，但他们确实报告说，当他们离开长椅时，他们觉得他的位置已经变了。
They commented that they thought it was strange that he wasn't moving because the mosquitoes were bad. But they didn't go in for a closer look and as they thought his position had changed they thought everything was okay. They got up and left and they didn't see anyone else before leaving. About 6am the next morning, Wednesday the 1st of December, two jockies were each riding a horse down on the beach. They rode past the Summerton Man but like John Lyons and his wife their initial thoughts were that it was just a drunk sleeping off a bender. However when they rode back up the beach they realised that he hadn't moved. He was in the exact same spot his head propped up against the seawall. It's a pretty awkward, unnatural looking position.
他们评论说，他们觉得奇怪的是他怎么一动不动，因为那里的蚊子很厉害。但他们没有走过去仔细查看，而且由于他们觉得他的位置变了，他们认为一切都好。他们起身离开了，在离开之前没有看到其他人。第二天早上6点左右，即12月1日星期三，两个骑马的骑师正骑着马在海滩上。他们骑马从萨默顿人身旁经过，但就像约翰·莱昂斯和他的妻子一样，他们最初的想法这只是一个宿醉的酒鬼在醒酒。然而，当他们骑马返回海滩时，他们意识到他根本没有动。他还在原来的地方，头部斜靠着海堤。这是一个相当别扭、看起来很不自然的姿势。
They went in to see if he was alright but he wasn't. The Summerton Man was dead. Now at this time John Lyons was actually back at the beach. He was going for a morning swim with a friend. The jockies and the bit of commotion caught his eye and he immediately recognised the Summerton Man as the same person he and his wife had seen the night before. He rushed over and called the police. Police officer John Moss was the first to arrive at the scene. He got there at about 6.45.
他们走过去看他是否还好，但并不是。萨默顿人已经死了。此时，约翰·莱昂斯其实已经回到了海滩。他正和朋友进行晨泳。骑师和一些骚动引起了他的注意，他立即认出萨默顿人就是他和妻子前天晚上看到的那个人。他冲过去并报了警。警官约翰·莫斯（John Moss）是第一个到达现场的人。他大约在6点45分到达。
He examined the scene and he found a half smoke cigarette that had fallen between the Summerton Man's cheek and his collar but there were no burn or blister marks on his face or clothing. The sands surrounding him wasn't disturbed, his clothing wasn't ruffled or dishevelled, there was no debris or personal items scattered around the beach. Basically he determined there were no signs of violence at all. A check of the Summerton Man's pockets found the unused train ticket, the bus ticket, two combs, one aluminium and one plastic. The aluminium came as thought to be from America as they were pretty rare in Australia at the time or they weren't actually available at all I don't think. A packet of juicy fruit chewing gum and a packet of Army Club cigarettes. But the cigarettes inside the packet of Army Clubs weren't Army Club, they were a different brand, Considus. There was also a box of Bryant and May's matches.
他检查了现场，发现在萨默顿人的脸颊和衣领之间掉落了一根抽了一半的烟，但他的脸部或衣服上没有烧焦或起泡的痕迹。他周围的沙子没有被扰动，他的衣服没有凌乱或散乱，海滩上也没有散落碎片或私人物品。基本上，他断定根本没有暴力的迹象。检查萨默顿人的口袋，发现了一张未使用的火车票、公交车票、两把梳子（一把铝制，一把塑料制）。那把铝制的梳子被认为是来自美洲，因为当时在澳大利亚它们非常罕见，或者我认为根本买不到。一包多汁水果口香糖和一包军团俱乐部（Army Club）香烟。但是军团俱乐部烟盒里的香烟不是军团俱乐部，而是另一个品牌——康西达斯（Considus）。还有一个布莱恩特和梅（Bryant and May）的火柴盒。
It was common at the time for people to buy an expensive brand of cigarettes, keep that box and then fill it up with cheaper cigarettes. It was just an image thing. But the funny thing about the Summerton Man is that the Considus cigarettes were the more expensive brand. Far more expensive than the Army Club box that he had. So this could have been a sign of someone who was trying to keep a low profile. An ambulance was called and they took the body to Royal Adelaide Hospital where a doctor came out and pronounced the Summerton Man dead. The time of death was estimated to be no earlier than 2am. But that is now considered to be a very rough estimate as the methods used to estimate the time of death back then not quite as good as what they do today.
当时人们很流行购买昂贵的香烟品牌，保留那个盒子，然后装满便宜的香烟。这只是一种营造形象的做法。但关于萨默顿人有趣的是，康西达斯香烟反而是更贵的品牌。比他拥有的军团俱乐部烟盒贵得多。所以这可能是某人试图保持低调的迹象。有人叫了救护车，他们把尸体送到皇家阿德莱德医院，在那里一位医生出来宣布萨默顿人死亡。死亡时间估计不早于凌晨2点。但现在这被认为是一个非常粗略的估计，因为当时用来估计死亡的方法不如今天那么好。
The post-mortem was performed the next day. Now what immediately stuck out about the Summerton Man was that he was a physical specimen in incredible shape, well-built, classic V-shaped body of an athlete. Someone physically strong yet he had very smooth hands with no calluses indicating that he didn't work in any job involving manual labour or heavy use of the hands. His hands were also described as being enormous. His fingernails and toenails were well cared for. And along with his impressive upper body physique he also had unusually well-developed calf muscles with a bulge near the knee. The coroner thought this was a sign that he may have been a professional dancer or a ballet performer or something similar. He was described or estimated to be about 45 years old, about 80 kilos. He was a Caucasian male. He was missing about 16 teeth overall but that wasn't at all uncommon at the time. In fact there's probably more common than not.
尸检于第二天进行。关于萨默顿人，立刻让人眼前一亮的是，他是一个身体健壮、体格惊人的男子，身材魁梧，具有运动员经典的V型身材。一个身体强壮的人，然而他却有着非常光滑的手，没有老茧，这表明他没有从事任何涉及体力劳动或大量使用双手的职业。他的手也被描述为大得惊人。他的手指甲和脚趾甲都修剪得很整洁。除了令人印象深刻的上半身体格外，他的小腿肌肉也异常发达，膝盖附近有隆起。法医认为这表明他可能是一名职业舞蹈演员、芭蕾舞演员或类似的人。据描述或估计，他大约45岁，重约80公斤。他是一个高加索白人男性。他总共缺了大约16颗牙齿，但这在当时一点也不罕见。事实上，这可能比不缺牙更常见。
Another unusual thing about the Summerton Man is that his spleen was three times the size of a normal spleen. Now this indicates a pre-existing illness that would not have happened quickly overnight at the time of his death. So I thought that he'd been carrying it for a while. It's evidence that he might have already been in a weakened state when he died. In large spleens can be a result of many illnesses including viral and bacterial infections, inflammatory diseases, even some cancers can cause that. He also had yellow stained hands indicating that he was a heavy smoker. His actual cause of death that was not immediately obvious but there were no signs of foul play so it was thought to be a natural death. His heart stopping although his heart was healthy so they couldn't put their finger on it straight away.
萨默顿人的另一个不同寻常之处在于，他的脾脏是正常脾脏的三倍大。这表明他患有某种既往疾病，这种疾病在他死时绝不是一朝一夕突然发生的。所以我认为他已经带病一段时间了。这证明他在死时可能已经处于虚弱状态。巨大的脾脏可能是许多疾病的结果，包括病毒和细菌感染、炎症性疾病，甚至某些癌症也会导致这种情况。他的双手呈黄色，表明他是个老烟民。他的真正死因并没有立即显现出来，但没有他杀迹象，所以被认为是一起自然死亡。他的心脏停止了跳动，尽管他的心脏很健康，所以他们无法马上找出原因。
The police certainly weren't treating it as a suspicious death in the early stages. They were convinced it wouldn't be too long before a relative or friend came forward and identified the body and the case would be finalised. A lot of people did come forward to try and identify the body as a missing relative or friend but no positive idea was made. After a few days it started to become a bit of a concern and on the 10th of December a decision was made between banning the body to preserve it in the hopes that in the coming days or weeks somebody would eventually show up and identify the body and the case could be finalised. But no one ever did. It didn't take long before the investigators, the medical people actually started to deviate off the natural death path and onto an unnatural death path. As I already said he had a healthy heart, there was no sign of heart disease or anything like that so there's nothing to suggest that his heart would just stop due to a heart attack or something.
在早期阶段，警方肯定没有把它当作可疑死亡来处理。他们确信，不久就会有亲戚或朋友站出来认领并确认尸体，然后案件就会结案。许多人确实站出来试图认领尸体，说他是失踪的亲戚或朋友，但没有做出确切的身份确认。几天后，这开始成为一个令人担忧的问题，12月10日，人们做出了一个决定：对尸体进行防腐处理以将其保存下来，希望在接下来的几天或几周内，最终会有人出现并确认尸体，从而结案。但没有人出现。没过多久，调查人员和医学人员就开始偏离自然死亡的道路，走上了非自然死亡的道路。正如我刚才所说，他有一颗健康的心脏，没有心脏病或类似迹象，所以没有任何迹象表明他的心脏会因为心脏病发作或其他原因而骤停。
Something had to have caused his heart to stop beating. And what the medical staff worked out is that they thought this something was poison. Samples were sent away for testing, the doctor in charge became convinced he was almost certain that they would return positive for poison. And he was of this belief because the some of the main stomach kidneys and liver were congested with a large amount of congealed blood, which is what happens when you're poisoned. Those organs don't just fill up with congealed blood for no reason, it certainly doesn't happen when you die a natural death. But certain as they had become now that poison was the cause of death, they could not find any sign of it. All the tests came back negative for poison, they couldn't detect a trace. There was one other problem too with the poison theory and that is there was no sign of vomiting as is usually the case with poisoning deaths.
一定有什么东西导致他的心脏停止跳动。医务人员得出的结论是，他们认为这个“东西”是毒物。样本被送去检测，负责的医生变得确信，他几乎可以肯定检测结果会对毒物呈阳性。他之所以有这种信念，是因为胃、肾脏和肝脏的一些主要器官里充满了大量凝固的血液，这就是中毒时的表现。这些器官不会无缘无故地充满凝固的血液，自然死亡时绝对不会发生这种情况。但是，尽管他们现在确信中毒是死因，他们却找不到任何中毒的迹象。所有的毒物检测结果都呈阴性，他们检测不到一丝痕迹。毒物理论还有一个问题，那就是没有像中毒死亡通常那样出现呕吐的迹象。
Dr Robert Cowan is the chemist who tested for the presence of poisons and he stated, I found no common poison present and I do not think any common poison caused death. If he did die from poison I think it would be a very rare poison, I mean something rarely used for suicidal or homicidal purposes. There are poisons that excrete from the body quickly, which would leave no trace and it's possible that the somatomere could have vomited elsewhere, even nearby, before eventually making his way down onto the beach where he died. To this day it's never been able to be proven that poison was the cause of death, although it can't be disproved either. But regardless, the coroner, the medical examiners and the police had now become certain that death was not caused by natural causes. They now just had to work out if it was suicide or murder.
罗伯特·科恩（Robert Cowan）博士是检测毒物存在的化学家，他表示：“我没有发现任何常见的毒物存在，我也不认为任何常见的毒物导致了死亡。如果他确实死于毒物，我认为那将是一种非常罕见的毒物，我是指那种很少用于自杀或谋杀目的的毒物。”有些毒物能从体内迅速排泄，不会留下任何痕迹，萨默顿人也可能在其他地方呕吐过，甚至在附近，然后才最终来到他死去的萨默顿海滩。直到今天，毒物是死因这一说法从未被证实，尽管也无法被反驳。但无论如何，验尸官、法医和警方现在已经确信，死因不是自然原因。他们现在只需要弄清楚这是自杀还是谋杀。
Once they started to work out that death was no longer natural, they assigned detectives to the case. And while there are no signs of foul play when the somatomere was found, there was something pretty unusual discovered. All of the identifying tags on his clothing had been removed. All gone, couldn't see whether clothes were made at all, no identifying marks, nothing. They had been deliberately removed. But had they been removed by the somatomere or by somebody else? The detectives immediately checked out Adelaide train station to see if there was any unclaimed luggage and they were in luck. This is where they found the somatomere suitcase.
一旦他们开始确定死亡不再是自然死亡，他们就指派了侦探来调查此案。虽然在发现萨默顿人时没有任何他杀迹象，但却发现了一些很不寻常的事情。他衣服上的所有身份标签都被取掉了。全都不见了，根本看不出衣服是在哪里制作的，没有任何标志，什么都没有。它们是被故意移除的。但这些标签是被萨默顿人自己移除的，还是被其他人移除的？侦探们立即检查了阿德莱德火车站，看看是否有无人认领的行李，结果他们运气不错。这就是他们找到萨默顿人的手提箱的地方。
Inside the suitcase there was nothing extraordinary, just the usual run-of-the-mill stuff. We had a dressing gown, a laundry bag, a pair of scissors, a knife, a stencil brush, a few singlets, some underpants, two tyres, a pair of slippers, a pair of trousers, a sports coat, a shirt, some handkerchiefs, envelopes, coat hangers, cigarette lighter, razor, shaving brush, towel, pencils, a scarf, a toothbrush. You know, nothing significant or unusual. But what did stand out is that even though the train ticket and bus ticket and other items were found on the somatomere, his luggage receipt was missing. That wasn't located on his body at all.
手提箱里没有什么非同寻常的东西，只有平常那些普通的东西。我们有一件晨衣、一个洗衣袋、一把剪刀、一把刀、一把模板刷、几件汗衫、一些内裤、两条轮胎（注：原文tyres疑为领带ties之误）、一双拖鞋、一条裤子、一件运动外套、一件衬衫、一些手帕、信封、衣架、打火机、剃须刀、剃须刷、毛巾、铅笔、一条围巾、一把牙刷。你知道的，没有什么重要或不寻常的。但引人注目的是，尽管在萨默顿人身上发现了火车票、公交车票和其他物品，但他的行李寄存收据却不见了。他的尸体上根本没有这个。
The detectives were just working on a hunch that maybe there was some unclaimed luggage at the train station. That's how it was found. So where was the receipt that he would have been issued when he checked the luggage in to the cloakroom? Did he lose it? Or did somebody take it? Just like on the somatomere, there was no ID in the suitcase. But how they were able to match it to him was that there was a piece of thread in the suitcase that they matched to the clothing that the somatomere was wearing, where his clothing had been repaired with this thread. The clothing sizes were also a match.
侦探们只是凭直觉认为火车站可能有一些无人认领的行李。这就是它被找到的方式。那么，他寄存行李到衣帽间时应该收到的收据在哪里呢？是他弄丢了？还是被人拿走了？就像萨默顿人一样，手提箱里也没有身份证件。但他们能够将它与他匹配起来的原因是，手提箱里有一段线，他们将其与萨默顿人穿的衣服进行了匹配，他的衣服正是用这种线修补的。服装尺寸也很吻合。
And also, they worked out that the suitcase was checked in to the cloakroom on the 30th, the day that he arrived in to Adelaide, which matches up with the tickets that he had. So that was enough to convince the detectives that this was definitely the somatomere suitcase. But it gets weirder, because just like on the somatomere, where all his identifying labels from the clothing had been removed, all the identifying labels from the items of clothing within the suitcase had also been removed. Well, most of them anyway. There were three things that they found a name the tag was still attached. On the laundry bag, they found a name printed on the label Keen, K-E-A-N-E.
此外，他们计算出该手提箱是在30日（他到达阿德莱德的那天）存入寄存处的，这与他拥有的车票相符。这足以让侦探们确信这绝对是萨默顿人的手提箱。但事情变得更加诡异，因为就像萨默顿人身上衣服的所有识别标签都被移除一样，手提箱内衣物的所有识别标签也都被移除了。好吧，至少大部分都被移除了。有三样东西他们发现名字标签仍然附在上面。在洗衣袋上，他们发现标签上印着一个名字：Keen，拼写为K-E-A-N-E。
On one of the singlets was also the name Keen, this time spelled K-E-A-N. And on one of the ties, there was the name T-Keen, K-E-A-N-E again. The fact that there's yet no identification had been made was really starting to concern detectives. Now, the somatomere's photo and fingerprints were sent all across Australia and overseas to try and help our team, but that didn't bring in any results. His identity remained a mystery. They went to work on the name Keen. Extensive checks were conducted, but they couldn't find any matches.
其中一件汗衫上也写着Keen这个名字，这次拼写为K-E-A-N。其中一条领带上写着T-Keen，又是K-E-A-N-E。至今仍未查明身份这一事实开始让侦探们真正感到担忧。现在，萨默顿人的照片和指纹被发送到整个澳大利亚和海外，以试图帮助我们的团队，但这并没有带来任何结果。他的身份仍然是个谜。他们开始围绕“基恩（Keen）”这个名字展开工作。进行了广泛的检查，但他们找不到任何匹配项。
There was no missing person reports, no other unaccounted full people, no unmatching that name Keen, who they could link to the somatomere. It was also very common at the time for people to buy secondhand clothing, and clothing had even been rationed out during the war, which had only just ended. So it's more than possible that the name Keen isn't the name of the somatomere at all. In fact, most believe it's not. Especially when you consider all the other tags had been removed from his clothing and from the suitcase itself. But those three items with the name Keen remained.
没有失踪人口报告，没有其他无法解释的失踪人员，也没有与那个名字Keen相匹配、可以与萨默顿人联系起来的人。当时人们买二手衣物也很常见，而且在刚刚结束的战争期间，衣物甚至实行了配给制。所以“Keen”这个名字根本不是萨默顿人的名字，这种可能性非常大。事实上，大多数人都认为不是。特别是当你考虑到他衣服和手提箱本身的所有其他标签都被移除时。但那三件带有Keen名字的物品却留了下来。
If he was trying to conceal his identity or somebody else was trying to conceal his identity after his death, the obvious thing to do would be to leave those tags on with the name Keen if that wasn't his name. This would provide a false lead and provide police with a bit of work to try and chase up down a dead end path. And when they found the suitcase, it was found unlocked. So the somatomere missing his luggage receipt, it's quite possible that after his death, someone took that receipt, went in, got the suitcase and tampered with it, rummaged to do it, removed the tags or removed other items that could either be him. If the tags weren't removed by the somatomere, we don't know.
如果他试图隐藏自己的身份，或者别人在他死后试图隐藏他的身份，显而易见的事情就是留下那些带有Keen名字的标签（如果那不是他的名字的话）。这会提供一个错误的线索，并给警察提供一些工作去追查一条死胡同。当他们找到手提箱时，它并没有锁上。所以萨默顿人丢失了行李收据，很有可能在他死后，有人拿走了这张收据，进去拿到了手提箱并对它动了手脚，翻找了它，移除了标签或其他可以辨认出他身份的物品。如果标签不是萨默顿人自己移除的，我们不得而知。
But it's definitely possible. This is the days before CCTV or anything like that, so you could quite easily slip in, go through the suitcase, put it back in for police to find. Police started doing checks on the clothing itself, and they found that the coat the somatomere was wearing was made in the United States. Also, the tie he was wearing had the stripes printed in a certain direction, indicating that it was also made in the United States. This doesn't mean the somatomere was from the United States, but certainly some of his clothing was.
但这绝对是可能的。这是在闭路电视或类似东西出现之前的日子，所以你可以非常轻松地溜进去，翻找手提箱，然后把它放回去让警察发现。警察开始对衣物本身进行检查，他们发现萨默顿人穿的外套是在美国制造的。此外，他系领带上的条纹朝向特定方向，这表明它也是在美国制造的。这并不意味着萨默顿人来自美国，但他的确有些衣物是美国制造的。
Just try and put yourself in the shoes of the detectives here. They've pretty much got no idea what's going on. They don't know who this guy is, where he came from, how he died, if it was suicide or murder. If it wasn't hard enough already, it was made harder because they started on the back foot from the get-go. Remember, they initially thought it was a natural death, then it was treated accordingly. Crucial evidence could have been lost. Not only was it 1948 and crime scene investigation techniques are now a year-level today. They forget about the same ballpark, it's not even the same game.
试着把自己放在这里侦探的角度。他们几乎完全不知道发生了什么。他们不知道这家伙是谁，他从哪里来，他是怎么死的，这是自杀还是谋杀。如果这还不够难的话，事情变得更难了，因为他们从一开始就处于劣势。记住，他们最初认为这是一起自然死亡，然后也得到了相应的处理。关键证据可能已经丢失。这不仅是1948年，当时的犯罪现场调查技术与今天的水平相比。别说在同一个档次了，甚至都不是同一场游戏。
And DNA evidence is still unheard of for another 40 years. But, I mean, they never gave themselves a chance. They were chasing their tail from the very start. As the investigation continued, the body of the somatomere was starting to deteriorate. The embalming was starting to wear off. So, a decision was made to have a plaster cast mould made of his head and upper torso area. And that still actually exists today. After this cast was made, the Somatomere man was buried.
而且DNA证据在未来的40年里仍然闻所未闻。但是，我的意思是，他们从来没有给自己机会。他们从一开始就一直在瞎忙活。随着调查的继续，萨默顿人的尸体开始腐烂。防腐处理开始失效。因此，决定为他的头部和上半身制作一个石膏模型。而那个模型直到今天仍然存在。制作了这个模型之后，萨默顿人就被安葬了。
He was buried on the 14th of June and a headstone was placed on his gravesite reading. Here lies the unknown man who was found at Somatomere Beach 1st December 1948. By now, another pretty important clue had been discovered. Just before the coronial inquest, a piece of paper was found crumbled up in the pants of the somatomere. It had originally been missed by investigators. And on that crumbled-up piece of paper read two words, tamanshur, that's Persian, meaning finished or ended. They immediately got to work trying to find out where these words could have came from.
他于6月14日下葬，他的墓碑上刻着：安息于此的是于1948年12月1日在萨默顿海滩发现的身份不明的男子。到目前为止，另一个相当重要的线索被发现了。就在验尸官研讯之前，在萨默顿人的裤子里发现了一张揉成一团的纸。它最初被调查人员漏掉了。在那张揉成一团的纸上写着两个字：tamanshur，那是波斯语，意思是完成或结束。他们立即着手弄清楚这些字可能来自哪里。
It looked like they'd been ripped out of a book. And they did find the book. Turns out, these two words were printed on the last page of a poetry book. The book was titled The Rubiant of Omar Koyam. Omar Koyam was a Persian poet, astronomer, philosopher and mathematician who lived from 1048 to 1131. The Rubiant of Omar Koyam is an English translation of a selection of his poems done by Edward Fitzgerald in the 1800s. The translations are pretty subjective and others have different interpretations of what the poems actually mean, but Fitzgerald is the most well-known.
看起来它们是从书里撕下来的。他们确实找到了那本书。原来，这两个字印在一本诗集的最后一页。这本书的书名是《鲁拜集》（The Rubiant of Omar Koyam，注：即Omar Khayyam的Rubaiyat）。奥马尔·卡亚姆（Omar Khayyam）是一位波斯诗人、天文学家、哲学家和数学家，生活于1048年至1131年。《鲁拜集》是19世纪爱德华·菲茨杰拉德（Edward Fitzgerald）对他的部分诗歌进行的英语翻译。这些翻译具有相当的主观性，其他人对这些诗歌的实际含义有不同的解释，但菲茨杰拉德的版本是最著名的。
It was a very popular book. The general theme throughout the book is one of seizing the day, living life to the fullest and dying without regret. They would eventually track down the actual book the somatomere ripped these words from, but unfortunately this book wasn't found until after the inquest. The coronial inquest was held over two days on the 17th of June and then again on the 21st of June, 1949. The coroner concluded, the identity of the deceased was quite unknown. His death was not natural and that it was almost certainly not accidental.
这是一本非常受欢迎的书。全书的总主题是及时行乐、充实地生活以及死而无憾。他们最终追踪到了萨默顿人撕下这些字的实际书籍，但不幸的是，这本书直到研讯结束后才被找到。验尸官研讯于1949年6月17日和6月21日举行，为期两天。验尸官得出结论：死者的身份完全不详。他的死不是自然死亡，而且几乎可以肯定不是意外。
It was noticed at the inquest how remarkably clean the somatomere and shoes were. That, along with the rest of his appearance, well kept fingernails, general clean and tidy appearance led the coroner to believe he wasn't a vagrant or a drifter. The inquest was adjourned to no fixed date, meaning the case would remain open and continue to be investigated and it could sit again if further information turned up. It was still thought that poison was the cause of death and two poisons in particular were mentioned that could have caused the death and remain undetectable. The names of those poisons weren't released to the public for many, many years after,
研讯中注意到萨默顿人和他的鞋子是多么的干净。这以及他的其余外表——修剪整洁的指甲、整体干净整洁的外表——让验尸官相信他不是流浪汉或流浪者。研讯无限期休会，这意味着此案将保持悬案并继续调查，如果出现更多信息，可以再次开庭。人们仍然认为毒物是死因，并特别提到了两种可能导致死亡且仍然无法检测到的毒物。这些毒物的名字在很多很多年之后才向公众公布，
as they were easy to obtain at the time and the last thing they wanted to do was give the public an easy undetectable way to kill someone. By now, the media had well and truly started to take a massive interest in the case. At first, the media had barely a passing interest, a man dying of what was initially thought to be natural causes on the beach, not exactly headlong grabbing stuff. But as time went on, the mystery surrounding the identity and the exact cause of the somatomere's death was starting to capture the public and media interest. Once detectives had linked the words Tamar and Shudd to the poetry book,
因为当时它们很容易获得，而他们最不想做的事情就是给公众提供一种容易且无法检测的方法来杀死某人。此时，媒体已经真正开始对这起案件产生了巨大的兴趣。起初，媒体只有一闪而过的兴趣，一个最初被认为死于自然海滩上的人，算不上什么吸引眼球的东西。但随着时间的推移，围绕萨默顿人身份及其确切死因的谜团开始吸引公众和媒体的兴趣。一旦侦探将“Tamar”和“Shudd”这两个词与诗集联系起来，
they made a public appeal if anyone had a copy of the book with a page or piece of page missing. Incredibly, on the 22nd of July 1949, a man came forward with a copy of the book with a piece missing from the exact spot where those words would have been printed. He said he found it on the back seat of his car and he has no idea how he got there. Never seen it before, thought it was unusual at the time but didn't think too much more of it till he saw a media release calling for a copy of the book. And of course, his car was parked at Summiton Beach right at the time the Summiton man died. He recalls his window was left unopened, pretty common at the time.
他们就向公众发出呼吁，看是否有谁拥有缺少一页或部分页面的这本书。令人难以置信的是，1949年7月22日，一名男子带着一本缺少一页的复本前来，缺少的正是印有那些字确切位置的那一页。他说他在自己的汽车后座上发现了它，他根本不知道它是怎么到那里的。以前从未见过，当时觉得很不寻常，但没多想，直到他看到呼吁寻找该书副本的媒体发布。当然，他的车就停在萨默顿海滩，正好在萨默顿人死的时候。他回忆说他的车窗没有关，这在当时很常见。
Police had that copy of the book that was handed in analysed and compared to the page that was found on the Summiton man that had a paper expert analyse it, and it was a 100% match. A piece of paper with the words Tamar and Shudd found on the Summiton man came from this book that had been handed in, that had been tossed into the back seat of a car. So the Summiton man had thrown the book into a random car that had its windows down at Summiton Beach. Why throw it into a car and not into a bin? Did he want someone to find it? Was he being followed and had to get rid of the book quickly?
警方对上交的那本图书进行了分析，并与在萨默顿人身上发现的带有纸张专家的那一页进行了比较，结果是100%匹配。在萨默顿人身上发现的写有“Tamar”和“Shudd”字样的纸片就来自这本上交的书，该书曾被扔进汽车后座。所以萨默顿人把这本书扔进了一辆停在萨默顿海滩、车窗开着的随机汽车里。为什么要扔进车里而不是垃圾桶？他是想让人找到它吗？他是在被跟踪，必须赶紧把书扔掉吗？
And was that his best option at the time? No one really knows. The identity of the man who came forward with the book is unknown. He requested to remain anonymous and police respected those wishes. The book itself is very popular and many copies exist, but this particular copy that was handed in is extremely rare. To this day, another exact copy hasn't been found. And it gets better. In the back of this particular copy of the Rubianne of Omar Kayan that this unknown person found in the back seat of his car,
那当时是他最好的选择吗？没人真的知道。主动交出书的那个男人的身份不详。他要求保持匿名，警方尊重了这些愿望。这本书本身很受欢迎，有很多副本，但上交的这个特定副本极为罕见。直到今天，还没有找到另一个完全相同的副本。事情变得更好了。在这个未知的人在他的汽车后座上找到的这本特定《奥马尔·卡亚姆鲁拜集》的背面，
there were four lines of letters handwritten at the back, some sort of code. To this day, it hasn't been broken. There's a link in the podcast description to the code as seeing it for yourself will be better than me trying to describe it, but there's four lines of letters. The code was published in the paper and amateur code breakers from all over the country got the work on the mystery. Many thought it may have been a code referencing back to the book of Omar Kayan itself. Top military code breakers have been consulted, but no one has been able to crack it for this day. Many have gone mad trying that.
背面手写了四行字母，某种密码。直到今天，它还没有被破解。播客说明中有一个指向该密码的链接，因为亲眼看到它会比我试图描述它更好，但有四行字母。该密码发表在报纸上，来自全国各地的业余密码破译者开始着手研究这个谜团。许多人认为这可能是指回奥马尔·卡亚姆之书的密码。曾咨询过顶级军事密码破译人员，但至今无人能将其破解。许多人为此发疯了。
What is significant about the code is that the second line is crossed out, and that crossed out line is very similar to the start of the fourth line, indicating whatever was being written was very deliberate and obviously a mistake had been made. But what if it's not a code itself? So maybe it's just an aid memoir, maybe reminding the writer of a certain poem or poems in the book, or maybe it doesn't even reference the book at all. Maybe whoever wrote it was just using a letter to represent a word, a sort of shorthand if you will. Whatever it is, it certainly adds a great deal of mystery to the case.
关于这个密码，意义重大的是第二行被划掉了，而被划掉的那一行与第四行的开始非常相似，这表明无论写什么都是非常刻意的，显然犯了个错误。但如果它本身不是密码呢？所以也许它只是一份备忘录，也许是在提醒写作者书中的某首或某些诗，或者它甚至根本没有引用这本书。也许写作者只是用一个字母来代表一个单词，如果你愿意的话，是一种速记。无论它是什么，它肯定为这个案子增添了巨大的神秘感。
And this code certainly bamboozled police if they weren't already bamboozled enough. It's also what leads many people to believe that the Summoner Man case is related to spies, secret agents, Cespionage. They believe the Summoner Man may have been a communist spy. Jason Bourne, James Bourne type stuff. When you put the code together with the missing labels, the lack of ID, and a few other things in the case that'll come up shortly, it actually doesn't sound too crazy. But we'll get into all that in a bit.
如果警察还没有足够糊涂的话，这个密码肯定把他们彻底搞糊涂了。这也是许多人认为萨默顿人案与间谍、秘密特工、间谍活动有关的原因。他们认为萨默顿人可能是一个共产主义间谍。杰森·伯恩（Jason Bourne）、詹姆斯·邦德（James Bourne）那种类型的东西。当你把密码与丢失的标签、缺乏身份证件以及案中不久后会出现的其他一些东西结合起来时，其实听起来并不那么疯狂。但我们一会儿会深入探讨这一切。
First we need to talk about the phone numbers that were also written down at the back of the book. There were two phone numbers written in the book along with the code. The first belonged to a local bank. The second was tracked to a local woman by the name of Jessica Thompson. Now for many, many years in this case her real identity was unknown. She was only ever known by a nickname of sorts, which was Justin. So if you do any reading on the case, you'll often hear mention of a mystery woman or Justin. Well, her real name is Jessica Thompson.
首先我们需要谈谈也写在书背面的电话号码。书里写着两个电话号码以及密码。第一个属于当地的一笔银行。第二个则追踪到了一位名叫杰西卡·汤普森（Jessica Thompson）的当地女性。多年来，在本案中她的真实身份一直不为人知。她一直只有一个类似昵称的名字，那就是“贾斯汀”（Justin）。所以如果你阅读任何关于这个案子的资料，你经常会听到神秘女性或贾斯汀的提及。好吧，她的真名是杰西卡·汤普森。
And her phone number was in the book along with the code that the Summoner Man had torn the words Tumlin should from. Not only was Jessica Thompson a local, she lived at Summoner Beach only about 400 metres away from where the Summoner Man was found. So it was starting to look like the Summoner Man didn't choose Summoner Beach randomly. He had a purpose to be there. On the 26th of July, 1949, nearly over seven months after the Summoner Man was found, police knocked on Jessica's door. They started asking her questions about the Summoner Man and she denied any knowledge. They also started asking questions about the Ruben Arnt of Omar Koyan poetry book. And she surprises them. She says, yes, that's my favourite book in poetry.
她的电话号码和密码写在书里，萨默顿人正是从那本书里撕下了“Tumlin should”这两个字。杰西卡·汤普森不仅是当地人，她就住在萨默顿海滩，距离发现萨默顿人的地方只有大约400米。所以事情开始看起来萨默顿人并不是随机选择萨默顿海滩的。他在那里是有目的的。1949年7月26日，在萨默顿人被发现近七个多月后，警察敲响了杰西卡的门。他们开始向她询问有关萨默顿人的问题，而她否认认识。他们还开始询问关于《奥马尔·卡亚姆鲁拜集》诗书的问题。她让他们大吃一惊。她说，是的，那是她最喜欢的诗书。
So the police were like, okay, do you own a copy? Jessica says, yes, I did, but I gave it away. Turns out she gave it away to a member of the military that she met in Sydney about four years earlier in 1945. His name was Alf Boxel. The police thought New Beauty case solved that Summoner Man is obviously Alf Boxel. And Jessica had given away a copy of the book with her phone number in it and for whatever reason, he's made his way to Summoner Beach and he's died. That was the thought anyway.
所以警察就问，好吧，你有一本吗？杰西卡说，是的，我有，但我送人了。原来她在大约四年前的1945年在悉尼遇到的一位军方成员送出去了。他的名字叫阿尔夫·博克塞尔（Alf Boxel）。警察心想：太棒了，案子破了，萨默顿人显然就是阿尔夫·博克塞尔。杰西卡送出了一本带有她电话号码的书，不管出于什么原因，他来到了萨默顿海滩并死去了。这至少是当时的设想。
Police took Jessica down to see the plaster cast that had been made of the Summoner Man and her behaviour was described as being quite odd. She couldn't really look at the plaster cast. After her first look at it, she stared at the floor. She only gave brief, simple answers to police questions. She looked like she was about to faint, basically showing all the signs that she knew exactly who the Summoner Man was. Jessica was married by now and she had two children, a son, Robin and a daughter, Kate. Robin was born first and Jessica's husband was not the father. A son known who the father of Robin actually is.
警察带着杰西卡去看了为萨默顿人制作的石膏模型，她的行为被描述为相当奇怪。她真的无法直视那个石膏模型。第一次看了一眼后，她便盯着地板。她对警察的问题只给出简短、简单的回答。她看起来快要晕倒了，基本上表现出所有她确切知道萨默顿是谁的迹象。杰西卡当时已经结婚，有两个孩子，一个儿子罗宾（Robin）和一个女儿凯特（Kate）。罗宾出生在先，杰西卡的丈夫并不是生父。至今无人知道罗宾的生父究竟是谁。
Jessica requested her name not be released so she didn't want any embarrassment to come to her family with her being linked to the Summoner Man. Police agreed. That's why for many years she was only known as the Mystery Woman or Gestant. Police got to work on the Althboxel theory and it wasn't long before their bubble was burst. They found him alive and well, living in Sydney. And he still had the copy of the Roubaillant of Omar Kion that Jessica had given him. She had inscribed a short passage in the book when she gave it to Alth and signed it to Gestant. That's how she came to be known by that particular nickname.
杰西卡要求不对外公布她的名字，这样她和“萨姆纳男”扯上关系就不会给她的家人带来任何尴尬。警方同意了。这就是为什么多年来她只被称为“神秘女子”或杰斯坦。警方开始着手调查阿尔思博克尔的理论，没过多久他们的幻想就破灭了。他们发现他还活着，而且过得很好，住在悉尼。他手里还留着杰西卡送给他的那本《奥马尔·海亚姆的鲁拜集》。她把书送给阿尔思时，在书上写了一段简短的段落，并落款为杰斯坦。她就是这样得到了这个特殊的绰号。
So not only was Althboxel alive, he still had his copy of the Roubaillant, meaning that the Summoner Man had a different copy of the Roubaillant with Jessica's phone number in it. As if this case wasn't strange enough, now this happens. The poor-eyed police at the time mustn't have known what had hit them. So how did Jessica and Althboxel come to meet? In 1945, Jessica was living in Sydney. She was training to be a nurse at the Royal North Shore Hospital. She spent a few evenings at the Clifton Gardens Hotel in Sydney, which was frequented by many military servicemen at the time.
所以不仅阿尔思博克尔还活着，他还留着他的那本《鲁拜集》，这意味着“萨姆纳男”手里拿着一本带有杰西卡电话号码的不同版本的《鲁拜集》。好像这个案子还不够诡异似的，现在又发生了这种事。当时那些焦头烂额的警察一定不知道自己遭遇了什么。那么杰西卡和阿尔思博克尔是怎么认识的呢？1945年，杰西卡住在悉尼。她当时正在皇家北岸医院接受护士培训。她曾在悉尼的克利夫顿花园酒店度过几个夜晚，当时那里经常有许多现役军人光顾。
It was here Jessica met Alth, a girlfriend of one of Alth's friends introduced him. They got together only for a few nights, shared a few drinks, and Alth was being put back on active duty for the war. So as a parting gift, Jessica gave him a copy of her favourite book, the Roubaillant of Omar Kion. Jessica left Sydney soon after she didn't complete her nursing exams. She moved to Melbourne for a brief period before settling in Adelaide. Jessica would have fallen pregnant with Robin around this time,
正是在这里，杰西卡经阿尔思的一个朋友的女友介绍认识了阿尔思。他们在一起只待了几个晚上，喝了几杯酒，然后阿尔思就被调回战争前线执行现役任务了。因此作为临别礼物，杰西卡送给他一本她最喜欢的书——《奥马尔·海亚姆的鲁拜集》。杰西卡不久后离开悉尼，她没有完成护士考试。她在墨尔本住了一小段时间，随后定居阿德莱德。杰西卡大概就是在这个时候怀上了罗宾，
and who the father is we don't know. Some suspect it could have been Althboxel, but there's others that suspect it could have been the Summerton Man. And remember, when the Summerton Man arrived in Adelaide, the only train from a major city that day was from Melbourne. So it was always assumed the Summerton Man came from Melbourne. Did the Summerton Man meet Jessica in Sydney, where she gave him a copy of the Roubaillant as well as she had given Alth?
而孩子的父亲是谁我们不得而知。有人怀疑可能是阿尔思博克尔，但也有人怀疑可能是萨姆纳男。而且记住，当萨姆纳男抵达阿德莱德时，那天来自大城市的唯一一列火车就是从墨尔本开来的。因此人们一直假设萨姆纳男来自墨尔本。萨姆纳男是否在悉尼见过杰西卡，就像她送给阿尔思一样，杰西卡也送了他一本《鲁拜集》？
Did he then try and track her down in Melbourne, only to find out she was now in Adelaide, and that's why he arrived there? To track down a former lover. Whatever the case, it was clear that Jessica was lying to police. She knew who the Summerton Man was. The daughter Kate would go on later, or many years later, was only recently in a 60-minute interview,
难道他随后试图在墨尔本追踪她，结果却发现她现在在阿德莱德，这就是他为什么去那里的原因？为了追踪前情人。无论如何，很明显杰西卡对警方撒了谎。她认识萨姆纳男。她的女儿凯特后来——或者说很多年以后，就在不久前的一次60分钟访谈中——
that she described Jessica as her mother as a woman with a very strong dark side. She even went on to say she thought she was probably a Russian spy. She found out one day that Jessica spoke Russian, but she wouldn't say where or why she learned it. This gives further weight to those that have always believed the spy angle. You have the code, the removed tags, the mystery identity, the mystery cause of death, which many believe to be undetectable poison, the behaviour of Jessica being deceptive to police.
她把母亲杰西卡描述为一个有着非常强烈的黑暗面的女人。她甚至接着说，她认为她可能是一个俄罗斯间谍。她有一天发现杰西卡会说俄罗斯语，但她不肯说是在哪里以及为什么要学的。这给那些一直相信间谍说的人提供了更多的分量。你有密码、被撕掉的标签、神秘的身份、神秘的死因（许多人认为那是无法检测出的毒药）、杰西卡对警方隐瞒的行为。
And to top it all off, Jessica said to a daughter one day that the Summerton Man is known to people at a much higher level than the state police. That's all detailed in a 60-minute story, which was done a few years ago, and there's a link to that in the podcast. There is another pretty significant piece of information that adds further weight to the spy angle. In 1946, a few hundred kilometres out of Adelaide, Britain and Australia entered into a joint project of missile and nuclear rocket testing.
最重要的是，杰西卡有一天对女儿说，萨姆纳男是比州警察高得多的人所熟知的人物。这一切都在几年前做的一期《60分钟》节目中进行了详细说明，播客中有一个指向该节目的链接。还有另一个非常重要的信息，为间谍说增添了更多的分量。1946年，在距离阿德莱德几百公里的地方，英国和澳大利亚联合开展了一个导弹和核火箭测试项目。
This would come to be known as the Woomera Testing Facility. So if this case does in fact involve the spy angle, there would be every reason for a Russian spy to be in Adelaide, the top secret rocket and missile testing facility that was nearby. Remember, this was the start of the Cold War, democracy versus communism. The Evil Reds, all that stuff. Certainly it is accepted that there were definitely spies in operation in Australia around this time. So now we have this top secret military testing facility.
这就是后来的乌默拉试验场。因此，如果这个案子确实涉及间谍说法，俄罗斯间谍完全有理由出现在阿德莱德，因为附近有绝密的火箭和导弹试验场。记住，这是冷战的开始，民主对阵共产主义。邪恶的红色分子，诸如此类的事情。当然，人们普遍接受这样一个事实：大约在这个时候，澳大利亚境内确实有间谍在活动。所以现在我们有了这个绝密的军事试验场。
So you add this piece of information to the code, the missing labels, the lack of identity, the unexplained cause of death, believed to be some sort of undetectable poison. You can see why this case has the attention of conspiracy theorists. One person that could have answered a lot of questions was Jessica, but she kept the cars very close to her chest. She definitely knew more about the case than what she laid on. Even towards the later years of her life, when it was still being investigated, she remained deceptive to police.
因此，如果你把这条信息与密码、缺失的标签、身份的缺失、无法解释的死因（被认为某种无法检测的毒药）结合起来，你就会明白为什么这个案子会吸引阴谋论者的注意力。有一个人本可以回答很多问题，那就是杰西卡，但她把底牌捂得很紧。她对这个案子的了解绝对比她透露的要多。甚至在她生命的晚期，当这个案子仍在调查中时，她对警方依然有所隐瞒。
Jerry Feltas, who was a cold case detective who took on the case in the 90s and still investigates it to this day in his retirement, he interviewed Jessica. He described there as being very evasive with her answers, even, you know, 50 years after the event. Not only that, whenever the case was brought back into the spotlight or was receiving publicity for whatever reason, Jessica would either disappear on holidays or leave town.
杰里·费尔塔斯是一位冷案侦探，他在90年代接手了这个案子，并在退休后的今天仍在调查，他采访了杰西卡。他形容她在回答问题时非常闪烁其词，甚至在，你知道的，事件发生50年后也是如此。不仅如此，每当这个案子重新成为焦点或出于某种原因受到公众关注时，杰西卡要么去度假消失，要么离开镇子。
But apart from spies and the possible love story angle which we mentioned, there is another possibility. World War II had just finished. Europe was in absolute chaos. You had the Soviet Union controlling Eastern Europe with the USA involved in Western Europe, communism versus democracy, the beginnings of the Cold War. The rule of the Soviet Union in the East was considered oppressive, and this led to a mass exodus of people looking to move and find a better life elsewhere.
但除了间谍和我们提到的可能的爱情故事之外，还有另一种可能性。二战刚刚结束。欧洲陷入了一片混乱。苏联控制了东欧，而美国则卷入了西欧，共产主义对阵民主，冷战拉开帷幕。苏联在东方的统治被认为是压迫性的，这导致大批民众为了搬迁并在其他地方寻找更美好的生活而大举出逃。
Australia was a very popular destination for these people. It was considered a safe place to live, especially when nuclear war broke out between the Soviets and the USA. Australia was a little more isolated from other parts of the world. Millions of people immigrated to Australia in the years after World War II. In 1948, the immigration policy was in full swing, and that was actually the peak time for the Australian government Displaced Persons Immigration Program,
澳大利亚是这些人非常热门的目的地。它被认为是一个安全的居住地，特别是当苏联和美国爆发核战争时。澳大利亚与世界其他地区的隔离度要高一些。二战结束后的几年里，数百万人移民澳大利亚。1948年，移民政策全面铺开，这实际上是澳大利亚政府流离失所者移民计划的高峰期，
which was specifically designed to help bring people to Australia who had been displaced from their homeland when World War II broke out. Of course, checks were conducted on everyone coming in, but how stringent were these checks? It wasn't uncommon for people to use false names, create new identities, a fresh start in a new homeland. It's quite possible that some of the men was one of these millions of immigrants that was flocking to Australia at the time.
该计划专门旨在帮助将二战爆发时流离失所的人带到澳大利亚。当然，对每个进来的人都进行了审查，但这些审查有多严格呢？人们使用假名、创造新身份、在新的国土上重新开始并不罕见。很有可能萨姆纳男就是当时蜂拥至澳大利亚的这数百万移民之一。
It would explain why no one was ever able to identify him. Not only were there lots of immigrants flocking to Australia, just stop and think about how many returning soldiers there were displaced and suffering. A high percentage were struggling with what we now know as PTSD and what was referred to as shell shock. And this led many soldiers to be displaced, become drifters, become estranged from their families. And that's another possibility in the case of the Summertime Man.
这就解释了为什么没有人能识别他的身份。不仅有大批移民蜂拥至澳大利亚，停下来想一想，有多少返乡士兵流离失所且饱受折磨。很大一部分人在与我们现在所知的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD，当时被称为炮弹休克）作斗争。这导致许多士兵流离失所，成为流浪者，与家庭疏远。这也是萨姆纳男案中的另一种可能性。
But of course, with so many questions and so few answers, each theory has its own pros and cons. The big glaring con for every theory is the unexplained cause of death. If Summertime Man was a displaced immigrant or a returning soldier, how could he just drop dead with a healthy heart and no other sign of healthy shoes, apart from the spleen, but, you know, no obvious cause of death, other than a lot of congealed blood pointing to poisoning. The same goes for the love angle.
但当然，由于有这么多的问题和这么少的答案，每个理论都有其自身的优缺点。每个理论最明显的缺点是无法解释的死因。如果萨姆纳男是一个流离失所的移民或返乡士兵，他怎么会突然倒地身亡，心脏健康且没有其他健康问题的迹象（除了脾脏），但是，你知道的，除了大量凝固的血液指向中毒外，没有明显的死因。爱情说也是如此。
If Jessica was a former lover of the Summertime Man, that explains why he was there, but it doesn't explain how he died. That's what leads many to go down the Jason Bourne James Bourne path. It's easy to explain his death if it was a common aspire. That's what spires did. Killed each other with undetectable poisons. Obviously, it was picked off by another spire who caught him out.
如果杰西卡是萨姆纳男的前情人，这就解释了他为什么会在那里，但没有解释他是怎么死的。这就是为什么许多人走上了杰森·伯恩/詹姆斯·伯恩的路线。如果这是一场普通的间谍阴谋，他的死就很好解释了。间谍就是这么干的。用无法检测的毒药互相残杀。显然，他被另一个识破他的间谍干掉了。
And that would certainly explain the code that was found in his copy of the Rubio Archery book and why all the identifying labels have been removed from his clothing. But if the Summertime Man was a spire, where does that leave Jessica Thompson in all this and why was her phone number in the copy of the Rubio Archery? The more you think about this case, the more your head starts to hurt. And while our heads are hurting, what about this?
这当然可以解释在他那本《鲁拜集》中发现的密码，以及为什么他衣服上所有标明身份的标签都被撕掉了。但如果萨姆纳男是一个间谍，这把杰西卡·汤普森置于何地？为什么她的电话号码会出现在那本《鲁拜集》里？你对这个案子思考得越多，你的头就开始越疼。在我们的头隐隐作痛的同时，这个怎么样？
Jessica's favourite book was called How It's End by A.M. Foster. The book is the story of a girl who has a son out of wedlock Her family tried to scare the girl's lover off, but in doing so, they accidentally killed him because he had a pre-existing, weak heart condition and the altercation caused him to die accidentally. Could that have been Jessica's way of telling us what happened to the Summertime Man without telling us what really happened?
杰西卡最喜欢的书是A.M.福斯特写的《霍华德庄园》。这本书讲述了一个未婚生子的女孩的故事。她的女孩家人试图吓退女孩的情人，但在这样做的过程中，他们不小心杀了他，因为他有预先存在的心脏病，争吵导致他意外死亡。这会不会是杰西卡在没有告诉我们真正发生了什么的情况下，向我们暗示萨姆纳男身上发生了什么的一种方式？
Could be, or could just be a favourite book. Who knows, it's just another part of a mystery. In 1945, three years before the Summertime Man case, a man by the name of Joseph George Saul Arm Marshall was found dead in Ashton Park in Sydney. His death was ruled as a suicide by poison. On his chest, he had a copy of the Rubio Archery of Omar Kayam. And that copy was also very rare
有可能，或者只是她最喜欢的一本书。谁知道呢，这只是谜团的另一部分。1945年，即萨姆纳男案发生的三年前，一个名叫约瑟夫·乔治·萨尔·马歇尔的人被发现死在悉尼的阿什顿公园。他的死被裁定为服毒自杀。他的胸前放着一本奥马尔·海亚姆的《鲁拜集》。而且那本书也非常罕见，
and just like Summertime Case, another copy just like it was never able to be found. A lady who went on to give evidence that the inquest was found dead 13 days later in a bath face down with a wrist both slit. That could just be a bit of random information, not related to the case, but it's still pretty odd. Moving forward to today, the case is still as mysterious and weird as it was back then
而且就像萨姆纳男案一样，另一本一模一样的书再也没有被找到。一位在死因研讯中作证的女士在13天后被发现脸朝下死在一个浴缸里，手腕双双被割破。这可能只是一些随机的信息，与案件无关，但它仍然非常奇怪。回到今天，这个案子依然像当年一样神秘和诡异，
and it still remains unsolved and is still open. There are two people thought to be experts in the case and links to their work have been provided in the podcast description. First is Jerry Feltas, a retired decorated detective who has investigated the case for many years. He's cracked some tough ones in his time, but even he hasn't been able to crack the Summertime Man. He's written an excellent book titled
而且它仍然悬而未决，案件仍在调查中。人们认为有两个人是该案的专家，他们的工作链接已在播客简介中提供。首先是杰里·费尔塔斯，一位退休的功勋侦探，他调查这个案子多年。他在其职业生涯中破解过一些棘手的案子，但连他也没能破解萨姆纳男案。他写了一本极佳的书，名为
The Unknown Man Detailing the Case, which I recommend checking out. The second person is Professor Derek Abbott from Adelaide University. He stumbled across the case several years ago and became fascinated, probably obsessed with the case. He's trying to get the body of the Summertime Man dug up for DNA testing. He's submitted two proposals so far and they've both been rejected.
《未知男子：详述此案》，我建议大家去看看。第二个人是阿德莱德大学的德里克·阿博特教授。他几年前偶然接触到这个案子并为之着迷，甚至可能到了痴迷的程度。他正试图将萨姆纳男的尸体挖出来进行DNA检测。他迄今为止提交了两份提案，但都遭到拒绝。
Fun fact, the two experts, Jerry Feltas and Professor Derek Abbott, aren't fiends of each other. But it can't be denied, both have done excellent work. I recommend checking both out. Professor Abbott actually appeared on a Reddit Ask Me Anything forum a little while ago and there's a ton of useful info on there, so there's a link to that on the podcast description as well as his website where you can see the original police statements and coronial documents.
趣事：这两位专家，杰里·费尔塔斯和德里克·阿博特教授，并不是朋友。但不可否认的是，两人的工作都非常出色。我建议大家去看看两人的成果。阿博特教授不久前实际上出现在一个Reddit的“问我任何问题”论坛上，上面有大量有用的信息，所以在播客简介中有一个指向该论坛的链接，以及他的网站，你可以在上面看到原始的警方声明和验尸文件。
As far as using today's technology to crack the case, well, the only chance of that happening is if Professor Abbott is ever successful in getting the body dug up for DNA testing because the Summertime Man's suitcase and all its belongings and even a copy of the Rubayant were all destroyed many years ago when Adelaide or South Australian police were doing their clean-out. So unfortunately, there's nothing really to test. Another fun fact about Professor Derek Abbott who's obsessed with the case
至于利用当今的技术来破案，嗯，发生这种事的唯一机会就是阿博特教授有朝一日成功将尸体挖出来进行DNA检测，因为萨姆纳男的手提箱、他所有的随身物品、甚至那本《鲁拜集》都在多年前阿德莱德或南澳警方进行清理时被全部销毁了。所以不幸的是，真的没有什么可检测的了。关于痴迷于此案的德里克·阿博特教授的另一件趣事是，
is during his time investigating the case, he met the daughter of Robin Thompson, who is Jessica Thompson's granddaughter. In meeting the daughter of Robin Thompson, he also met her daughter, Jessica Thompson's great-granddaughter, and he married her. They have three children together. He has a pretty interesting theory. He's convinced that the Summertime Man was a former lover of Jessica Thompson and they had a child together, that child being Robin Thompson.
在他调查此案期间，他遇到了罗宾·汤普森的女儿，也就是杰西卡·汤普森的孙女。在结识罗宾·汤普森的女儿时，他也遇到了她的女儿——杰西卡·汤普森的曾孙女，并娶了她。他们育有三个孩子。他有一个相当有趣的理论。他坚信萨姆纳男是杰西卡·汤普森的前情人，两人育有一子，那个孩子就是罗宾·汤普森。
These theories, the Summertime Man is a case of a former lover, possibly a jilted lover who knows tracking down Jessica to Summertime Beach for reasons unknown, whether he's trying to rekindle the relationship or Professor Abbott even thinks that due to the enlarged spleen that the Summertime Man may have already been dying and he knew he was dying and maybe that's why he finally tracked Jessica down, maybe to try and, you know, one last goodbye or whatever and that went however, when then he made his way to the beach
这些理论认为，萨姆纳男是前情人案，可能是一个被抛弃的情人（谁知道呢），出于未知的原因追踪杰西卡来到萨姆纳海滩，无论他是试图重修旧好，还是阿博特教授甚至认为由于脾脏肿大，萨姆纳男可能已经快死了，他知道自己快死了，也许这就是他最终追踪到杰西卡的原因，也许是想去，你知道的，做最后一次告别之类的，不管怎样发展，然后他来到了海滩
and died of natural causes and just hasn't been able to explain. He's not convinced that he was poisoned. Now he's raised his conclusion just due to all the circumstances of the case and also because of a particular feature on the year of the Summertime Man which is also shared by Robin Thompson and it only appears in 1-2% of the population. So what are the chances of both of these people, you know, sort of linked in this way in the case of sharing this unusual feature of their ear? You know, you certainly look at it and you think it's quite possible,
并死于自然原因，只是无法解释。他并不确信他是被毒死的。现在他得出这个结论，仅仅是因为案件的所有情况，还因为萨姆纳男耳朵上的一个特定特征，这个特征罗宾·汤普森也有，而且它只出现在1-2%的人群中。所以，这两个以这种方式产生联系的人在案件中共享他们耳朵上的这种不寻常特征的几率是多少？你知道的，你当然会看到这一点，并认为这是非常可能的，
especially when you learn that years, surprisingly enough, are actually considered to be quite good identifiers of people, not as good as fingerprints, but pretty close. So if that is the case, it still doesn't really explain his death. Natural causes was pretty much ruled out by the medical examiners at the time. So many possibilities, a spy, a former lover, a displaced immigrant, a displaced soldier or there's so many more theories on top of that. The only thing we do know is we have no idea who the Summertime Man was,
特别是当你了解到，令人惊讶的是，耳朵实际上被认为是相当好的身份识别器，虽然不如指纹，但也相当接近。所以如果情况确实如此，它仍然没有真正解释他的死。当时的法医基本上排除了自然原因。有太多的可能性：一个间谍、一个前情人、一个流离失所的移民、一个流离失所的士兵，或者除此之外还有更多的理论。我们唯一知道的是，我们根本不知道萨姆纳男是谁，
where he came from or how he died. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他来自哪里，或是他是怎么死的。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。